you
and how you doing good good good to see
you good to have you here Thanks so what
we're talking about is disruption and
the dilemma that industrial companies
face when new digital essentially
disruptors come into their industry so
we've talked about retail we've talked
about commerce we've talked about new
hardware products and we've talked about
finance
now we want to move more to some
complete different industry healthcare
and life sciences so why don't you just
like maybe set the picture of what is
23andme why'd you start it come what was
the origin how did it all come about
okay so I started 23 me after investing
in healthcare companies for about 10
years so 23 is now about 10 years old
and we started we started with some of
the principles that I learned when I was
on Wall Street and the main one was that
the consumer being all of you actually
has no voice in healthcare and that it's
a system that's really odd because
everyone above you is selling to each
other but it trickles down to you but
you don't actually have a voice in all
these processes and um and I found it
actually really insulting like
personally insulted volunteer in
hospitals and you start to see how all
this money is being made and all these
decisions are happening that are not
always in your best interest and I saw
the HIV community and the HIV community
in the 90s was angry and aggressive and
demanded transparency and they had
groups like there was a famous group out
in San Francisco called Project inform
and project inform was led by a patient
advocate who like kept all the patients
up to date with resistant data and what
was happening what was coming and they
went they actually went and they stormed
the FDA at one point you can see this
footage of like them coming in and
breaking in they were super aggressive
and if you think about patient advocates
if you can contrast that with groups
like komen and LIVESTRONG where there's
just much more of this more sort of
accepting take of you know oh people are
going to take care of me and they're
gonna do stuff whereas the HIV community
demand it
transparency and I realized I wanted to
see more of that anger fight the
consumer that they wanted to take
control back of their own healthcare and
I almost see the today's healthcare
consumer is akin to a communist society
inhabitant where they're so used to this
system taking care of them that they're
just completely apathetic to actually
taking charge of themselves and they
just defy like they don't take the
responsibility for themselves because
they're so used to other people actually
taking making decisions for them
so 23 meat was intentionally set out as
a mission driven company with the idea
that we actually wanted to drive change
it was not set out with a traditional
business plan it was not set out with I
want to make money in these kinds of
ways and then I'm trying to monetize you
know a new reimbursement strategy it was
set out that I want to activate an angry
population that wants to drive change in
health care and so what we did is we
said there is a revolution happening in
genetics where you can go and get your
you could get a genome-wide coverage so
it's not your entire genome but it was a
lot of the important variations in your
genome and you can get that pretty
cheaply and then I started to see this
trend of Facebook and LIVESTRONG and
like all these communities coming
together because people want to share
and and being in the valley and also my
father's a particle physicist here who
like physics was the science that
pioneered a lot of big data work and so
you start to I have this background and
you want big data to really understand
the body and human disease and health
and wellness super-complicated you know
in retail stores that figure this out
like Walmart and Target
you walk into the store and they know
what you're gonna buy and I kept
thinking like well if I can go walk into
my doctor they should know what I've
been doing they should know what I'm
likely to be developing in five years
they should predict what diseases I'm
likely to get and we do some of that
with family history but the idea is how
could I actually empower the consumer to
actually take control one of the most
exciting scientific developments that's
come and then also create this database
of information so that then we can
actually
we transform healthcare and so the
mission of 23 million was about enabling
consumers to access understand and
participate in and benefit from the
human genome and so we enable the
direct-to-consumer model so you go
online you could order the kit it
started out at almost a thousand dollars
you order it it's a little kit you spit
in it you mail it back to us two to four
weeks later or maybe six weeks later you
get back the email that said welcome to
you and the goal was you know we just
enabled access traditionally healthcare
you know it's hard to get you have to go
through someone it's expensive etc you
don't know how many you're gonna do it's
do insurance so we enabled the access
and now we want you to understand it so
we've tried to make it really simple
with this belief that anyone can be a
scientist you don't have to have a PhD
you don't have to have a white coat
anyone could be a scientist so we've
enabled you to understand it and then
when we launched our research
initiatives we said now you're actually
gonna benefit from it because we don't
understand what the majority of the
genome actually means and so the way
we're gonna actually decipher what the
human genome means is not to wait for
all the NIH grants to happen and for
people to figure it out but that we the
consumers who want to actually see this
happen we're gonna be the ones figuring
out what the genome means and we're
gonna be the ones that are benefitting
it so that was the start I think I
answered most the question I was
actually 80% I guess the question is a
like how did the industry get to be the
way it is today and how far out of
communism are we are we like 1940s China
like what are we talking about yeah so I
think I think one of my moments on Wall
Street when I decided that I had to
leave as I walked into this conference
in DC and it was like a giant was like
one of those giant DC hotel lobby was
like massive and there's all these
people in bad suits like just dark bad
suits and it was a conference on
optimizing billing codes mmm and I
realize there must been a thousand
people in this room and I realize like
this system is never gonna change so
many people make money
on Health Care's in efficiencies it's
not going to change from within I
remember I had one healthcare executive
who's like came out to the valley she's
like you Valley people like so excited
about whatsapp you know 18 billion
dollars
it's my glove budget yeah like people
don't realize the amount of money 2.7
trillion dollars in health care it just
Dwarfs everything else so when you think
about changes like when Matt when there
comes out to be a new you know Congress
actually sets like payments for certain
kinds of drugs that has massive hundred
million dollar or billion dollar swings
on things so the system is set up in a
way that all these other people are
fighting over these massive pools of
money but because you aren't don't have
a voice I think it's it's not really the
efficient system you want I think one of
the biggest issues that we have is that
nothing and when you talk about problem
in the system is that there's no way you
monetize diabetes or no way you monetize
wellness so if I think about trying to
keep you healthy instead of actually
becoming diabetic if I can actually
prevent diabetes is largely preventable
and if I succeed in doing that no one
makes money from the system but all
these companies like make money on
treating diabetes and managing all the
other types of consequences from it and
I think that's when their problems is
because there's no monetization
intervention
there's no money in prevention do you
think the leaders of the large companies
don't want to change who they want to
keep it the same or do you think they
don't know how I think there's no
financial path to change and if you were
running those companies would you be
doing the same thing because that's the
financial incentive that's put in front
of you as a leader well I think that's
you so most the healthcare companies
have a fiduciary responsibility to
maximize the bottom line and so like I
met one hospital company and they came
to me and they're like this back when I
was on Wall Street and he's like we're
so excited we're seeing margin expansion
because we moved collections into the
emergency department so when we get them
like we get him on the gurney and so
like they come in and like and so you
know there's like part of it that I'm
saying is like there's a sick element of
how healthcare happens and it's not that
these people
I always say healthcare is a system
that's filled with good people but the
ship is pointing the wrong way so if
everyone's like off to go and make you
know discoveries in but they're pointed
to Alaska like it's just it's it's you
know you're just the ships the wrong
direction Arthur
are there certain business models in the
incumbent side of healthcare that that
benefit from that I have an incentive
structure that is aligned with the
patient and with the individual so I
think when you're countable care
organizations as an example right so I
think one of the most interesting things
that's happened in healthcare lately is
Obamacare so I actually think that
Obamacare coming in has created I came a
couple things came up that made me think
about it has really disrupted so
everyone has to be covered in this
country everyone has a right to be
covered so people when they worry about
insurance and such when I used to talk
to insurance companies I'd ask different
questions like Oh would you discriminate
against someone who found out their
carrier for CF and they'd be like yeah
that's what we do and so the day after
Obama was re-elected one of the
insurance called and they're like
like we you know like this is Obamacare
things really gonna stay and we're
supposed to keep people healthy and we
make money off discriminating and so do
you know how to keep people healthy and
and like that's you know it's it's a
little bit of the reality it's like
there was like there's a joking and when
I was on Wall Street that insurance
companies would recruit Medicare
patients on the second floor of walk-up
buildings because you're selecting for
the healthy and and so there's like
debris out there's all kinds of gains
because you're trying to sort of you
know you're playing the game what do you
actually just super
I just tangent what do you think about
that that that pharma kid in Wall Street
the yeah I think it's I mean those are
the types of things and would yeah will
you see it like it was one of the things
that we used to talk about at home like
yeah you can just raise drug prices as
much as you want and so normally like he
really exploited it normally it's
slightly more subtle right and like
they'll do it in smaller increments but
it's going up all the time right but
yeah and I mean he really went more
crazy with it right what um so okay so
what is the so where does 23andme fit in
- then I guess driving then change what
is the where do you see your role in
then empowering individual to make
either different choices about what
healthcare providers they go to or you
know making different life decisions
from so that was one of the things I
think is the interesting change with
Obamacare is that there's been this
whole movement now of actually getting
healthcare into places where people are
going and so if you see Walmart actually
has introduced a number of different
like the $40 wellness checkup so you can
go in there and you can get a $40
doctor's visit Kaiser you should have
talked to Bernard about this Geysers in
target in Southern California there's
all kinds of ways that retail is
becoming sort of the hub of where you're
actually going to be experiencing your
healthcare so when I think about some of
the big transitions that are gonna
happen there it's gonna be potentially
like you start absorbing a lot of your
health care on your mobile phone like
you call a bunch of doctors you take a
picture of your mole you send it out to
ten positions or you start going into
retail stores where you're naturally
going and okay but so that's a how
that's the shift toward retail where do
you guys fit into then enabling the
individual so so I think what we have
done and in the early days people were
kind of people used to always ask
they're like am I allowed to get this
data am I allowed to post it online cuz
we would enable people to like easy
access to posts on Facebook and they're
like are you allowed to post that your
abraca carry are on Facebook so I think
one of the most important things that
we've done is we just wake up that
Communist patient consumer just just say
like you're actually like you actually
you have the ability to ask questions
like you don't have to do what your
doctor tells you you don't you have the
right to get your data you don't you
have the right to actually ask like
what's it gonna cost and like these are
just like basic things like in any other
sector I mean it's one of the things I
think is interesting even with the fact
that you're having this conversation
like every other sector has been
disrupted mmm-hmm except for health care
like health care we still sort of all
accept like when you go into the doctor
like you fill out the form like we just
kind of accept that it's going to be a
horrible experience so I think the most
important thing that we've done is we've
tried to actually say the consumer
should have a voice in this and I think
with Walmart and other groups coming in
if you think about someone's
you're high risk for type 2 diabetes and
you go to Walmart and they say oh great
aisle seven like running shoes workout
DVDs so there's an economic lift to them
in the prevention market whereas if you
ask Bernard about what we're not Kaiser
is different but if you talk to sort of
the majority of Hospital group so you
talk to Stanford for instance Stanford
they are going to be they're gonna have
less focus on the wellness because they
make the hospital makes money by people
coming in do you think it's a
generational issue
I've spoken with physicians and they'll
often say when the younger generation
comes in they feel like they're asked to
defend what their recommendation is for
the patient whereas if an older patient
walks in the older patient just does
what he or she as the doctor recommends
do you think what you're empowering is
kind of that next generation coming up
and it'll be driven more by the youth
yeah I think without a doubt I think
that there is a general generational
divide where people are used to the
white coat is the is the symbol of
authority and you follow what they say
and this is a generation that's really
that's grown up with like everyone here
is like grown up with WebMD but when
WebMD came out it was just wildly
controversial doctors hated WebMD and it
was just like one of those things like
everyone talked about how much like it's
a it's like it's they're challenging the
physician like it was wildly
controversial and it's accepted today
that of course you go and you research
your disease what okay so you now have
how many total customers have four can
you say 1.2 million 1.2 million got it
okay so you have 1.2 million sort of
profiles of genetic data and genetic
information what I guess are a you
allowed to do with that and what are you
starting to think about doing that you
you brought in the a pretty senior
individual from Genentech to start to
play around with kind of new new
business models their take us into I
guess the future of the the business so
uh so first off all customers they come
in and we ask them to consent for
research so over 80% of customers are
consenting for research today we an
affinity because when people talk about
the I Tunes you know their Terms of
Service like we actually really want
people to read it because there's
nothing worse that's like we don't we
don't want people who have who aren't
interested in really participating it
because there's there's no bet they're
not gonna take the survey it's like if
you're not interested in research they
don't take the survey so then it's not
valuable and I should emphasize that our
reefs
Church is only valuable if you take the
surveys because what we're doing is
we're looking at the genetic information
and then we look at all the people for
instance who say they're left-handed or
all the people who say they have
diabetes and then we do genetic analysis
with that information business well so
so in terms of so the goal really was
how are we benefiting like how are we
all going to go and benefit from the
genome and we have a team in-house that
actually does analysis and does research
and obviously we hired Richard Scheller
from Genentech so we're doing our own
therapeutics and the original thought
was that we were going to partner with
all the academics and all the pharma
partners out there because we actually
believe like that was gonna be the
fastest way for us to understand what
the human genome means and we have in
the consent policy that we have is that
your your genome is yours and so we have
you given essentially 23 me the ability
to do research on it but we will never
give anyone else your genetic
information without your explicit
consent so there's really two aspects
like one we can't do research without
your consent and two we will never
actually give away your genome we'll
never sell there's all these all kinds
of speculation like oh are you selling
individual genomes we will never do that
without explicit consent and so the goal
has been how is it that we can actually
partner with the research world and the
pharma companies to actually get as much
understanding in the genome as we can
and that's where I'm amazed you know and
as much as in the privacy debate I'm
perpetually amazed at how many people
actually want to participate and when I
email customers about do they want to
participate in an Alzheimer's study
funded by a pharma company do you want
to participate the consent rates are
incredibly high like people and I think
something that to tap into in healthcare
is that if you're somebody who's sick if
you're somebody who has Alzheimer's or
somebody who has lupus disease or some
other you know incurable condition you
want to cure you're not worried about
HIPAA you're not worried about the
privacy if there's some way to have a
cure but you want to participate in that
and I think that's where the current
research process is incredibly
frustrating so you you are you
monetizing that sort of lead acquisition
okay so that's one form of monetization
which is you can find participants in
different tests that are much more kind
of you know very much more appropriate
for that test because of all the genetic
data that you have right usually what
happens as farmers originally we're
coming out to say like we want to do you
know we want to do an analysis on lupus
patients and you have X number of people
in this so can you run what's called a
genome-wide Association study so
originally we're sort of genetics
research for hire we have done a number
of different research projects with
pharma companies as well where they just
run a want run queries in the database
so they work with the team they'll say I
have these questions I want you to run
these queries in the database and we
give them back the results a few pharma
companies have now paid for us to build
out communities for them so like we are
building out a lupus community where we
go and we actively recruit lupus
patients who become lupus customers and
then we ask them survey questions
regularly and we're looking to see is
there it's is there a genetic
association with the disease so in part
a lot of the work that we are doing with
pharma is is just very basic research
about the disease as the CEO of this
business what are the types of people
you need to hire mean you've got
community builders you've got it sounds
like Pharma researchers if you're
looking to build your team what are the
skill sets and functions you need in
your company so I think that's one of
the hardest parts of 23 me is that it's
it's a complicated business like it's
definitely was not simple and in some
ways the beauty of it like being out
here we brought together we wanted to
bring together like the Genentech world
plus the you know the tech savvy world
and you know in our team we hired for
instance a VP of market from we our VP
markings from Netflix and our head of
international sales froze from eHarmony
and then we have you know Richard
Scheller who ran R&D for 15 years at
Genentech so those people don't really
speak the same language normally and so
we have to hire people who are really
good developers like we have to have
people who can understand the consumer
and the engagement and and the whole wet
like that experience and how would you
take really complicated information and
make it accessible to people and then we
have to hire pretty sophisticated
bioinformatics
and those people are incredibly hard to
find and so there's a real dogfight in
the valley over hiring those people
yeah we're hiring a toilet box yeah so
what okay see you got you've got this
you got this sort of maybe lead
acquisition approach for for research
experiments you know hypothetically you
could even maybe target you know drugs
at certain individuals and have a you
know maybe we don't do any of that got
it got a cool we don't we're like
further or earlier in the chain like
we're right I think we're like an early
Rd partner
not even as a lead acquisition like we
do early R&D okay and we also do R&D in
a way so when my favorite things we do
research that is otherwise impossible to
do so one example is like we did
research projects on people who have two
mutations in one mutation has a
frequency of 1 in 10,000 people and the
other mutation has a frequency of one
and a thousand people and so you can
imagine that it's essentially impossible
to find people who have both mutations
so we did a project we had 24 of those
people in the database we emailed them
to see if they want to do punch biopsies
which is like taking a piece of skin
from your arm to make stem cells so we
email them and in 24 hours eight people
consent yes to do so we're not paying
then we're not doing anything but they
consented for it but otherwise like
we're enabling a world of research that
otherwise never could have even a mat
that imagined and which is one of the
things I think is really cool is like
including the genetic component enjoy by
having a huge database that wasn't
necessarily structured to say oh it's
just a schizophrenia database or another
type it's just broad all-comers so who
who then do you who are you disrupting
what part of the supply chain or value
chain of of the life sciences kind of
process are you disruptive to because
it's clearly not ancestry.com so like
what yeah so we I mean I think one
things as challenges it's like we step
on a lot of toes in one of the like some
of the bigger toes that we step on our
other academic partners okay because you
know you look at some of the big groups
and they can say they get a grant they
get an NIH
brant for ten million dollars to study
schizophrenia and that involves
recruiting people and doing these
studies and like there was actually a
study that came out in Parkinson's and
you looked at the paper and there's like
20 authors on it was multiple years
multiple centers you can just look at
the paper like that probably cost ten
million dollars and we saw it and we the
result came out we just ran the analysis
in our database it took four hours and
and then we got the same results and
we're like oh like and so it's much
cheaper so for like for me it I can
almost draw that parallel and you guys
are all so young you don't remember this
but in the old days if you wanted to go
on a trip you had to like go to a travel
agency and you'd get brochures about
hotels and you it was just complicated
and it was so hard to just like figure
out what you want to do and there's
someone out like now you just do a query
and we want to do the same type of thing
almost in genetic studies like oh you
want to know what types of conditions
are associated with you know people who
you know are night owls you just run a
query and that's what the team like the
team that I hired from Genentech that's
what they do they just like are running
queries all day and they're like it's
amazing like the amount of research we
can just do it we just run the query and
the data is all there so when we're
sitting here in 2021
and we're having this conversation again
what's 23andme gonna be like at that
moment in time what's your business
gonna be like where's the revenue coming
from I think first and foremost we're
always consumer focused like I you know
and it's it was really interesting
hearing all the different discussions
like here about what who we at who our
competitors are and what we are I'm
really passionate about in the reason
why like I focus on like the reason I'm
at the company still and like I try to
maintain a lot of control over it is
because I care a lot about the consumer
involvement in this and and I think for
us like I'm really interested in the
wellness like everyone at some point
like you want I want to see a world
where we actually understand the
Wellness I want to see a world where no
one takes an antibiotic who doesn't know
if they're gonna have an adverse event
where you actually know you know most
people take antidepressants and
antihypertensives and I am antibiotics
and they have no idea if it's gonna work
or if they're gonna have side effects
like it's kind of a crazy I think we
will look back at one point and say like
oh
crazy form of Medicine so I think that's
one thing and then I think two on the
drug discovery side I think that drug
discovery today is mostly done in mouse
models and part of what we're doing part
of what we're disrupting here is that we
are we're starting with the human and
I'm having I have the hypothesis that if
I start with the human and I have tons
of data that my hypotheses have a higher
likelihood of success in drug
development than hypotheses that come
out of mice and so is that will that
play out and that's part of the
experiment to see but I'm I'm I'm hoping
that we will by that time frame that we
will right and in that future state do
you do drug manufacturing and drug
distribution drug marketing or do you
partner with J&J and you know Eli Lilly
Amgen maybe we know which one I don't
know I mean either I think I think both
of them are viable options I think what
to me that's like a logistics
practicality okay it's like so not it's
it will figure out like what it whatever
is the best way to actually get it out
there I mean the main reason we whatever
we do we will do in a different way and
I think that's part of what keeps us
honest because we're consumer driven
there's there's something about your
data set and the amount of kind of you
know just like you're not having to deal
on models or or simulations if a mouse
is sort of a simulation you get the rod
the raw data do you get to then either
discover drugs that otherwise you know
maybe are not you know being being
discovered otherwise and you can go do
research in areas that nobody paying
attention to so this is a real-world
example of actually what's to come out
now so there is a genetic variant in a
gene called pcsk9 and what happened is
they discover that there is that you
know you have HDL and LDL levels and
there were certain people who have
incredibly low LDL levels and these
people came into the clinic and they
actually sequenced them and they found
they had a mutation in a gene called
pcsk9 and if you have that mutation you
just have incredibly low low levels of
LDL and so there's now five pharma
companies today developing drugs to try
and mimic the same
process that happens when you have that
mutation in the drug so in some ways
it's these what we call superhero
studies find people with really
interesting extreme phenotypes and then
understand their genetics and so you can
look at that like why is it that some
people could like theirs is obvious like
why is that some people can live to a
hundred why is it that some people could
eat sugar all the time and they don't
become diabetic so is there you know why
is it that some like I have no cavities
I have my everyone has a superhero
quality in themselves but why is it that
I have no cavities like what is it that
is in everyone that makes everyone
unique and and is there some is does
that lead to some kind of drug pathway
so I mean then in this five-year or
ten-year future could we see like an
order of magnitude increase in the
amount of drugs out there and they're
highly specialized to me and everything
gets way more personalized are you the
one I'm looking to also change and I
also don't know how many people realize
this is that drug development is wildly
ineffective and so it's roughly 2
billion dollars to develop a drug and so
there's and it only gets more expensive
like there's really no other industry
that brags about how they get more and
more ineffective every single year and
so we're looking to try and change that
like could you actually go from start to
finish and develop a drug for 300
million dollars instead of 2 billion 0
is there some way that you could
massively describe and I think that to
me will have a huge impact like there's
so many poorly treated diseases and and
also diseases need to be classified like
not all breast cancer is breast cancer
how do you actually subdivide it and
then you'll have much more personalized
treatments that have a genetic basis so
we would be actually coming into a
Renaissance and all of life sciences
then yeah I think that I think that
there's a big change that could happen
in drug discovery and I think that's the
hypothesis that house of that play out I
think in the immediate term when I think
about the next five years it's about
driving this consumer revolution and I
think that more and more as you know
people who have never lived a day of
their life or their adult life without
Facebook they just find it crazy to like
have the health care system as it is and
so I think that's where you're gonna see
more and more of this awakening of the
consumer movement in health care last
question how should
the FDA think about you and I think just
all of this innovation in general right
we you you have a regulatory environment
that is used to an industrial world
where it's a ten year process of
developing the drug it's gonna cost a
couple of billions a couple billion
dollars there's gonna be lots of lawyers
involved it's gonna be a very slow
moving process
how do you deal with a world where
there's a lot of data it's very dynamic
there's gonna be maybe algorithms
changing the very nature of a medical
device and so it's not something that's
sort of fixed and static what how do you
think the FDA should be updating or
responding and kind of regulation in
general in this space so I think the
best thing that the FDA needs to do is
they need to set up an office out here
yep because I think that there is you
know they're really used to a drug
coming on to the market or medical
device coming on the market and it
doesn't change and this idea of like
scrum development or what like is
absolutely terrifying
so I mean it's part of what we struggle
with in in just terms it like every like
the healthcare is changing and I think
that were to me the healthcare landscape
is like internet in the 90s like it is a
barren landscape and it's about to be
built and it would be a tragedy if
regulation is what holds it back and so
they have been actually putting like
Stanford has a really good program where
they have FDA leaders coming out here
regularly but it takes both sides like
one of the things I say out here people
out here need to understand DC better
and understand that you know you know
someone asked me on a recent meeting
like oh you know are those five 10ks
that you have to feel are they online
like do I just download it and no one
here laughed literally when I told that
to the FDA regulators they're like oh
that's like the best thing ever
because there is no forum I'm just in
case you're wondering
you have to like it's a little bit of
like this if this iterative guessing
process to figure out how exactly how
does regulation happen so I think both
sides are gonna have to really come to a
better understanding and spend more time
together in order for it to actually
help move the needle forward are you
hopeful that I guess under certain
future administrations that would
probably get even slowed down even
further right so are you hopeful that
that is actually gonna happen in the
next couple years
yeah I mean I think I think that the
ship has sailed in terms of like
technology is coming in to health
right and I think that there's without a
doubt there is a realization that they
are going to they need to get up to
speed and and they're putting real
effort into it I mean that's part of it
with you know Obama has a big funding
that's actually a lot more money has
gone now into the FDA there is without a
doubt a real need for you know
tech-savvy people to be there okay cool
and thank you very much